senna
dans gauche vous souhaitez succéder à
madame marion guillou qui a exercé de
had a mandat renouvelé c'est à dire deux
mandats de quatre ans qui exerce
également de 40,4 jusqu'à vos prochains
jours oui vous avez exercé différentes
missions que vous et sans de nous
rappeler nos côtés en sachant bien que
l'inra est le premier institut de
recherche économique européen dans le
domaine de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et aussi de le côté
environnemental
donc je vous invite monsieur prin bref
rappel du fonctionnement de cet
établissement mais je crois que c'est
pas là dessus qu'on va passer du temps
je pense que tous les membres de la
commission connaissent l'inra pour avoir
éventuellement des stations
expérimentales ou des laboratoires près
de chez eux dans différentes réparties
sur le territoire
donc c'est un le pst et ce qui nous
intéresserait plus évidemment c'est
votre projet stratégique pour gérer et
développer
l'inra est en tous les cas ce que je
souhaite si vous êtes retenu c'est qu'il
n'arrive pas à l'inra les mêmes choses
qu'il est arrivé à l'inserm own c'est
neyret c'est à dire à transformer
simplement en une agence de moyens
vous voyez ce que je veux dire derrière
je pense que vous avez gardé une
certaine indépendance pour un projet de
recherche etc et donc bien sûr dans le
contexte qu'on connaît
voir comment vous avez vécu le résultat
des programmes d'investissements
d'avenir
les fameux pays acp et la coopération et
un petit sujet qui m'intéresse plus
particulièrement qui est le sujet des
pgm
connaissant la position de marion
guillou sur le sujet j'aimerais savoir
si vous êtes en ligne sur l'avenir des
pgm je vois les abeilles qui sourit mais
moi le slogan non aux ogm est une
arnaque intellectuelle je le redis
posément ne peut pas y avoir un certain
nombre de produits de vaccins et c à 101
des organistes chesnais génétiquement
modifiés oui michel je vais m'approcher
de ton oreille et donc j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que vous pensez en particulier
de ce qui est arrivé à colmar sur une ne
jeudi un programme de élaboré avec tous
des associations avec toutes les
précautions qu'on peut imaginer
concernant le corps noués et donc
j'aimerais bien mais que vaut là dessus
vous dis ne disait quelques mots mais je
sais que les choses forcément évolueront
quand on aura 9 milliards de plus de
l'habitant sur la planète pour nourrir
comment on fait si en plus se conjugue
le changement climatique
voilà vous avez la parole on vous écoute
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis très
honoré de m'exprimer aujourd'hui devant
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat qu'on aurait dit le premier
ministre envisage de proposer ma
nomination au président de la république
et honorer aussi que la ministre de la
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur et
le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la flore et et
préalablement proposé mon nom je suis
aussi sensible au fait que c'est au
sénat que s'exprime le mieux tous les
territoires de notre pays territoires
dans lesquels vous savez aussi bien que
moi inra est profondément ancrée alors
c'est la première fois que cette
prescrit dur s'applique à l'inra et
c'est donc un moment particulièrement
important
je me présente à vous à la fois comme le
scientifique et comme administrateur de
la recherche chez pleinement conscience
qu'il s'agit d'un poste de haute
responsabilité dans la recherche et
d'innovation un rôle déterminant à jouer
dans une société de la connaissance
conscience aussi que les activités
l'inra concerne un secteur majeur de
l'économie française et plus
généralement un domaine comme vous
l'avez dit l'alimentation l'agriculture
et l'environnement qui est essentiel
pour l'avenir de nos sociétés dans mon
intervention je vais donc essayer de
limiter un peu moins de vingt minutes je
dégagerai les points forts de mon
parcours partagerai avec vous ma vision
des enjeux de la recherche agronomique
et de sa place d'un système national de
recherche d'innovation et vous exposerai
enfin les grandes lignes de l'action que
je conduirai si vous m'accordez votre
confiance
quand dans ma carrière j'ai découvert de
l'extérieur puis de l'intérieur
différentes facettes de l'inra de ses
personnels de ses activités et de ses
partenaires en tant que doctorant en
tant que partenaires extérieurs moi même
en tant que directeur d' unité mixte de
recherche que chef de département
directeur scientifique puis directeur
général délégué mes activités m'ont
conduite a exercé différents métiers
ingénieurs enseignants chercheurs
chercheurs gestionnaires de la recherche
et ses métiers je les ai exercé dans
différents environnements au ministère
de l'agriculture au ministère des
affaires étrangères dans et avec
différents organismes de recherche
l'inra évidemment mais aussi le cirad le
cnrs ird et des universités des écoles
d'ingénieurs
j'ai ainsi travaillé avec de nombreux
opérateurs français et européens ou
internationaux comme avec des acteurs
sur
économiques ou des porteurs d'enjeux
publics et privés mes activités
personnelles
on portait plutôt sur la production
l'écologie la biodiversité des forêts
tempérées et tropicales et sur la
modélisation des plantes elles se sont
élargies à d'autres domaines en inde
quand j'ai eu la chance de diriger
l'institut français de pondichéry et un
institut pluridisciplinaire qui allie
écologie géomatique et sciences sociales
et humaines dans un cadre pas
d'européens
lorsque j'ai présidé l'institut
forestier européen et puis à l'inra
évidemment comme directeur scientifique
en charge du secteur des productions
végétales puis comme directeur général
délégué supervisant l'ensemble de son
dispositif scientifique dans ses
dernières fonctions à l'inra gilles
porte une grande attention la cohérence
entre nos orientations scientifiques
nationales et leur inscription
territoriales j'ai ainsi mis en place
des groupements d'intérêt scientifique
qui associe l'ensemble des acteurs
publics et privés concernés
quand je pense notamment qu'on demande
intérêts scientifiques biotechnologies
vertes qui implique non seulement il
s'intéresse le cirad cea l'ird et l'inra
mais aussi des instituts techniques des
semenciers des pôles de compétitivité et
des entreprises de l'aval des filières
végétales
j'ai aussi développé la fonction de
programmation de l'inra pour traiter de
grands enjeux dont certains que vous
avez évoquées l'adaptation de
l'agriculture au changement climatique
la gestion intégrée et durable de la
santé animale et de la santé des
cultures ou la sécurité alimentaire donc
à 53 ans je me présente devant vous fort
de cette expérience et de quelques
convictions j'ai le goût de la
collaboration entre disciplines entre
individus et entre partenaires qui ont
des missions des fonctions différentes
mais qui ont des ambitions et des
objectifs partagés
j'ai aussi le goût des allers retours
entre l'approfondissement des
connaissances élargissement de leurs
champs leurs synthèses et leur
transmission leur assemblage leur
transformation en innovation en savoir
faire une application concrète
je suis convaincu que les objets réels
pose en retour de très belles questions
recherche et qu'elles méritent ils
méritent que les scientifiques s'y
intéresse
et puis j'ai un fort intérêt pour la
coopération scientifique internationale
aussi bien parce que la recherche par
essence et internationale que parce que
les défis qui nous sont adressées
aujourd'hui à la recherche agronomique
sont de portée globale
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
je recueille votre confiance et que si
je suis nommé à la tête de l'institut
national de la recherche économique
c'est donc cette expérience ce sont ses
compétences et ses convictions que je
mettrai au service de l'inra un moment
particulier où je pense que nous en
avons tous conscience l'effort partagé
la solidarité nationale sont nécessaires
ou les sciences de la vie ouvre des
perspectives remarquable où il est
attendu de la science qu elle irrigue la
formation l'innovation et de la
recherche agronomique qu'elle contribue
à l'émergence d'une bio économie et aux
transition écologique et énergétique
indispensable je voudrais maintenant
vous dire quelques mots sur la manière
dont je vois la recherche agronomique
qui me semble être au coeur d'enjeux
majeurs au 21ème siècle nos sociétés
doivent relever trois défis assurer la
sécurité alimentaire pour neuf milliards
d'êtres humains qui sont devenues
majoritairement urb urbain préserver les
ressources naturelles les sols l'eau la
biodiversité et plus généralement notre
environnement et pallier la raréfaction
et le renchérissement des ressources
fossiles notamment du carbone fossile
l'interdépendance et la conjonction de
ces trois défis on renforce l'acuité et
tous trois interpelle l'agriculture ils
sont au coeur des enjeux du
développement durable et de l'émergence
d'une bio économie fondée sur les usages
les usages du carbone renouvelable et
sur la connaissance des régulations
écologique ainsi que sur la conception
de nouveaux systèmes agricoles et
agroalimentaires que nous devons
considérer dans toute leur complexité et
relever ces défis suppose de mobiliser
une science qui soit à la fois
excellente de qualité et pertinente et
qui soit belle et utile alors vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le président le
domaine stratégique de la recherche
agronomique est défini par un tripode
l'alimentation condition première du
bien-être des populations humaines et
qui met en jeu un tissu d'un truc
d'industries agroalimentaires
l'agriculture qui recouvre un ensemble
d'activités humaines
t'es con
les économique principalement dédiée à
cette finalité alimentaire et puis
l'environnement dont les ressources et
milieux sont indispensables à
l'agriculture et qui sont en retour
façonné par l environnement dont il
convient de préserver la qualité et les
fonctionnalités pour les générations
futures
alors ce domaine tente à s'élargir au
travers d'interaction croissante avec
d'autres ceux du climat
ceux de l'énergie de la chimie la santé
humaine ou des développement périurbain
si vous m'accordez votre confiance c'est
cette vision de la recherche agronomique
centré sur le tripode alimentation
agriculture environnement mais aussi
ouverte aux grands enjeux connexes que
je viens d'évoquer de la recherche
agronomique ancré dans les
développements les plus récents des
sciences de la vie mais aussi ouverte à
d'autres disciplines et de la recherche
agronomique développement des approches
systémiques requise par la complexité
même des questions posées que j'entends
promouvoir quand vous savez ce domaine
stratégique de recherche est essentiel
pour la société française à plusieurs
titres
j'en citerai un ici le secteur agricole
et agroalimentaire un point important
dans l'économie et l'emploi
c'est le premier secteur excédentaire de
la balance commerciale en 2011
mais nous savons tous que c'est aussi un
secteur dont la fragilité et le besoin
de compétitivité sont connus c'est aussi
un domaine qui est important pour les
paysages les territoires l'emploi
environnemental les services écologiques
et pour le bien-être et la santé des
citoyens
si vous m'accordez votre confiance
l'inra sera donc mobilisé pour appuyer
par ses recherches par ses capacités
d'innovation par ses capacités
d'expertisé ces liens la formation et
ses partenariats sociaux professionnels
et par un dialogue accru avec la société
conques l'inra sera mobilisé pour
l'élaboration de nouveaux modèles
agricoles et de nouveaux systèmes
alimentaires alors vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président l'inra et le
deuxième institution de recherche
agronomique au monde dans le champ de
l'agronomie
c'est la première en europe depuis l'an
l'institut a accru significativement
l'impact et le nombre de ces
publications
plus de trois mille huit cent en 2011
soit un accroissement 60 % depuis 2000
il a affirmé son leadership dans l'étude
des fleurs du tube digestif par les
approches les plus récentes de la
métagénomique il a acquis une place
privilégiée en europe où il participe un
plus de 200 projets et coordonne par
exemple l'initiative conjointe entre les
initiatives de programmation conjointe
qui est dédié à la sécurité alimentaire
et l'adaptation de l'agriculture au
changement climatique
nous constatons aujourd'hui un regain
mondial d'intérêt pour l'agriculture et
pour la recherche agronomique avec par
exemple l'émergence de nouveaux grands
acteurs scientifiques internationaux en
chine au brésil en turquie
nous constatons aussi que des organismes
plus académique en europe hors grande
bretagne en allemagne par exemple se
réoriente vers la recherche agronomique
l'une de mes priorités sera évidemment
de maintenir le leadership de l'institut
dans ce contexte
dans ce contexte vous l'avez évoqué
l'inra est un organisme national public
de recherche finalisée
il est donc partie prenante du système
national de recherche et d'innovation
il en est l'un des opérateurs majeurs
aux côtés d'autres organismes
d'établissement et d' agences dont les
missions sont complémentaires
l'inra dispose d'un patrimoine
expérimental et d'infrastructures
scientifiques qui sont originales et
dont la pérennité de renouvellement sont
essentielles qui avec son budget de près
de 850 millions d'euros avec ses 8500
personnels titulaires ses 49 unités
expérimentales répartis sur le
territoire
c'est 200 unités de recherche dont les
deux tiers sont mixtes avec d'autres
organismes avec des universités avec des
écoles ou des instituts techniques il ne
rate au coeur d'une communauté
scientifique et technique qui accueille
bon an mal an 1800 étudiants et
chercheurs étrangers et qui implique
plus de 1000 agents d'autres
établissements et donc si vous
m'accordez votre confiance je
m'attacherai faire vivre ces tensions
entre mission nationale de l'institut et
ancrage territorial entre attractivité
ouverture et entretient à long terme de
son patrimoine
je souhaite enfin soulignait la
diversité des missions d'un organisme de
recherche finalisée produire des
connaissances nouvelles et au meilleur
niveau
bien sûr mais aussi contribuer à
l'innovation et à l'émergence de
nouvelles ingénierie éclairer les
politiques publiques par la synthèse de
connaissances et la prospective assure
un vivier d'experts pour des agences
dédiées participé à la formation et la
diffusion des connaissances et puis
s'engager dans des débats sociétaux
si vous m'accordez votre confiance je
veillerai donc à ce que l'institut
continue à remplir pleinement ses
missions au sein du système national de
recherche innovation et je porterai une
grande attention à la qualité à l'impact
et au volume évidemment des productions
qui sont attachés à chacune des missions
que je viens d'énoncer alors quelles
seront les principales lignes d'action
comme vous l'avez indiqué l'inra est
dirigée depuis 2004 par un président
directeur général qui assure à la fois
son pilotage interne ça président la
présidence du conseil administration et
les relations avec l'ensemble de la
puissance publique et plus largement de
la société nos priorités ont été fixées
dans le cadre de son contrat d'objectifs
2012 2016 qui sous tendue par le
document d'orientation 2010 2020 je
m'attacherai ici à préciser la manière
dont je vois leur mise en oeuvre et je
propose ainsi deux lignes d'action animé
par une méthode de travail et des
valeurs affirmées alors la première
ligne d'action que je vous propose
concernera l'ingénierie la production
scientifique
j'ai dit en effet que continuer à
améliorer la qualité et l'impact des
productions d'instituts qu'elles soient
académiques ou tourner vers les usagers
de la recherche et l'undp sera l'une de
mes priorités
et c'est en effet la clé du leadership
de l'institut du respect dont ils
bénéficient aujourd'hui dans le monde et
de sa légitimité dans la société
et si vous m'accordez votre confiance je
m'engagerai sur trois points essentiels
qui permettent un organisme public de
recherche finalisée de remplir ses
missions ses compétences sa
programmation et ses infrastructures de
recherche qui me paraît effectivement
important de garantir les compétences de
l'institut sa capacité à explorer
nouveau front de sciences et maîtriser
les trajectoires d'impact qui vont
depuis la découverte et l'invention
jusqu'aux applications et aux
innovations
je souhaite aussi développer la capacité
de programmation dînera sur les grands
enjeux et les grands tournants d'origine
scientifique technologique et économique
sociétal ou environnementale et à ce
titre là je prolongerai le mouvement qui
étaient engagés par l'initiation des
grands programmes dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure par exemple gestion intégrée de
la santé végétale ou gestion intégrée de
la santé animale ou adaptation au
changement climatique et je veillerai à
des aides qu'ils y associer davantage
les partenaires de l'institut qu'est ce
que ces unités pleinement la possibilité
de s'y engager
cette capacité de programmation je crois
que vous l'avez évoqué est effectivement
essentiel pour un institut de recherche
finalisée ce type que l'inra et
troisième point je consoliderait et
organiser les infrastructures
scientifique collective de l'institut
parce qu'elle fonde son originalité son
efficacité son attractivité
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure les
investissements d'avenir
je veillerai entre autres à la mise en
place des deux démonstrateurs
préindustriels dans le champ de la
métagénomique du tube digestif et dans
le champ des biotechnologies blanches
donc je veillerai la mise en place de
ces deux démonstrateurs préindustriels
et des infrastructures nationales qui
ont été sélectionnés dans le cadre des
investissements d'avenir est alors bon
couplage aux activités de recherche que
nous avons est par ailleurs à leur
ouverture est le rayonnement la deuxième
ligne d'action que je souhaite
promouvoir ou suivre ça consiste à
promouvoir la recherche agronomique dans
différents écosystèmes année un
organisme public national de recherche
finalisée se définit effectivement aussi
par ses partenariats et accroître
l'efficacité et le rayonnement de la
recherche agronomique dans différents
écosystèmes de recherche innovation aux
échelles régionales nationales
européennes et internationales me semble
effectivement essentiel dans le contexte
que j'ai déjà évoqué si vous m'accordez
votre confiance je poursuivre ainsi
trois d'action majeure
l'internationalisation de l'institut jeu
consoliderez ses partenariats avec les
autres acteurs français de la recherche
et de l'enseignement supérieur et
l'approfondir et ses interactions avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés par la
recherche agronomique premiers points
tout en maintenant notre engagement ou
son engagement qui est déterminant en
europe je souhaite poursuivre
l'internationalisation de l'inra à ce
titre en prenant appui sur les grands
programmes déjà cité et sur la montée en
puissance d'agreenium qui est un
consortium de recherche et de formation
agronomique et vétérinaire tournée vers
l'international et qui rassemble cirad
l'inra et plusieurs écoles d'ingénieurs
en privilégiant les collaborations avec
les grands opérateurs homologues de
l'inra dans le monde et en privilégiant
certaines régions notamment la
méditerranée et en amplifiant
l'implication l'inra dans des
initiatives de grande portée à l'image
de ce qui a déjà été engagée dans le
cadre par exemple de l'alliance globale
de recherche sur les gaz à effet de
serre en agriculture ou plus récemment
de l'a8 initiative qui est une
initiative du g20 sur l'agronomie
duration génétique du blé initiative qui
est coordonné par l'inra en lien avec le
bibi et cerci son homologue britannique
et le ch'ti mythe qui est au centre
agronomie qu'international en deuxième
lieu et en complément de la
participation agrium et dans le respect
de son statut d'organisme national
j'appliquerai l'inra de manière
équilibrée dans les dynamiques nationale
et territoriale de structuration du
système national de recherche et
d'innovation et je souhaite
effectivement que l'inra contribuer
activement aux alliances nationales de
recherche tout particulièrement mais pas
exclusivement à l'envi l'alliance qui
est dédié à la recherche
environnementale notamment
l'alimentation à l'eau au climat et aux
territoires et parallèlement je souhaite
développer une politique territoriale
élaboré avec les partenaires que ce soit
des écoles des universités d'autres
organismes de recherche et qu'ils soient
déclinées dans le cadre d' espaces
collaboratifs de projets respectueux des
missions respectives des uns et des
autres enfin et puis le dé ce dernier
point pour moi essentiel je vais dire
aux interactions d'instituts avec
l'ensemble des forces vives de la
société afin qu'il continue à jouer son
double rôle de pionnier et de garde-fous
je pense ici à tous les acteurs des
filières des territoires et du
développement agricole et instituts
techniques les coopératives les chambres
d'agriculture et aux autres emprise
notamment entreprises de taille
intermédiaire avec ses partenaires ces
interactions pourront prendre appui sur
des instruments existants des unités
mixtes technologique des pôles de
compétivité des groupement d'intérêt
scientifique et sur les trois instituts
carnot
coordonné par l'inra qualité des
aliments filière du carbone renouvelable
santé animale récemment créé et puis sur
le consortium de valorisation thématique
d'allant vie
la collaboration avec l'inra doit être
un facteur de compétitivité pour ses
partenaires mais parce que cette
collaboration respectives caractère
public de l'institut je favoriserai les
dispositifs collaboratif qui sont
largement ouverts et qui associe des
acteurs européens ayant une base de
recherche portent en france et puis jean
france enfin aux citoyens notamment ceux
qui sont engagés dans le secteur
associatif de la consommation ou de la
protection de l'environnement et avec
eux je souhaite explorer de nouvelles
modalités d'engagement notamment en
développant des sciences participatives
se trouve en fait que nos objets de
recherche les aliments l'eau les plantes
les animaux leur maladie les abeilles
les sols les paysages du forez parle à
nos concitoyens et les impliquer
davantage dans nos projets peut-être une
manière collectivement fructueuse
renouveler cet engagement ces deux axes
je souhaite les décliner selon la
méthode de travail que j'ai suivie dans
mes fonctions précédentes contact direct
respect mutuel dialogue solidarité
collective dans la mise en oeuvre des
choisi des décisions je serai notamment
a dit attentif à tirer parti des idées
et des initiatives individuelles et à
toutes les comparaisons pertinentes à
favoriser les formes collégiale de
gouvernance et à simplifier
l'organisation de l'institut par une
compréhension partagée des fonctions et
des rôles des différentes structures
cette méthode elle vise à garantir la
cohérence et la mobilisation de la
commune travaille dans un contexte
exigeant où la cohésion sera un facteur
de réussite
il sera nécessaire de moderniser notre
gestion est de faire évoluer notre
modèle économique de telle sorte que les
ressources contractuels contribuer à
financer dimension collective de nos
activités
en résumé à la tête de l'inra je
souhaiterais que celui ci délivre une
science qui doit nous en france l envi
de la comprendre qui donnera envie à ses
partenaires de collaborer et d'en tirer
des résultats utiles et puis qui donne
envie aux techniciens aux ingénieurs et
aux chercheurs de rejoindre l'institut
et d'y travailler
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la vision de la
recherche agronomique démission de
l'inra que je me propose de porter dans
le cadre des futures assises de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
voici mes engagements si vous m'accordez
votre confiance et que je suis nommé à
la tête de cet institut je vous remercie
de votre attention et suivi damman
disposé à répondre à toutes vos
questions
j'ai bien noté qu'il y en avait quelques
unes sur les investissements d'avenir
sur les organismes génétiquement
modifiés
ces plantes génétiquement modifiées ou
sur les investissements d'avenir vous
sur les alliances a retenu je sais que
vous avez accélérer votre débit un peu
je voulais une figure imposée parce que
je souhaitais que nos deux collègues qui
sont en train de de nous quitter qui
vont à l'office parlementaire pour le
renouvellement du bureau suite à
l'élection des députés puisse vous avoir
entendu et donc je les autorise
exceptionnellement à voter après vous
avoir entendu
voilà pourquoi il y avait une donc la
parole est à madame nico oui monsieur
ollier donc je vous remercie pour cette
présentation tout à fait complète et
intéressante sur vos projets concernant
future direction de l'inra
moi j'avais une deux questions
concernant alors ce que l'on appelle ici
les plantes génétiquement modifiées et
non pas les ogm puisque tu assistes sur
cette appellation
ma question est relative à la
conciliation entre ses recherches sur
ces plantes génétiquement modifiées et
le maintien de la biodiversité
puisqu'il y a en la matière et vous
venez parler justement des abeilles
quelle influence il peut y avoir sur la
coexistence entre ces plantes et là le
maintien de dés des abeilles par exemple
et d'autres éléments de notre
environnement qui concerne la
biodiversité
d'autant que le goût des français pour
le bio est quelque chose qui est
croissant donc comment concilier les
deux et ma deuxième question concernera
plutôt la communication des travaux
effectués par l'inra vous n'en avez pas
tellement parler mais je pense que c'est
important dans le rôle que cas cet
institut au niveau national et
international
de quelle manière envisagez vous de
communiquer les travaux de recherche qui
peuvent être effectués par cet institut
pour rendre les choses plus accessible
aux français
merci je crois qu'on va comprendre
quelques-unes et puis après je pense
qu'il risque d'y avoir des recouvrements
sans doute
monsieur pierre hérisson merci monsieur
le président j'ai oublié ma question
porte d'abord merci pour votre
présentation et la détermination qui est
la vôtre à travers vos propos je
voudrais vous interpeller sur étant
moi-même membres d'un comité de la faim
moment où les agences de l'eau présente
et propose aux différents comités de
bassin le dixième programme je crois que
nous avons à la fois une volonté
exprimée par plusieurs agences je prends
celle de rhône méditerranée corse 3
milliards 600 millions d'euros pour le
prochain programme 2013 2017 dont 1
milliards affectés à la protection des
milieux aquatiques qui est une
répartition du jamais vu mais qui est
très importante compte tenu de la
nécessité de la préservation du doute
mais parallèlement on nous dit alors
c'est pas seulement la rumeur c'est
aussi peut-être avec j'allais dire
l'ambiance générale de vouloir
localement diminuer le budget des
agences et par voie de conséquence leurs
moyens je voudrais savoir ce qu'il en
mais je prendrai un exemple le votre
agence qui a en plus une activité un peu
internationale puisque elle est à
proximité du lac léman mais le long du
fleuve rhône celle de thonon les bains
où on s'inquiète
malgré la contribution des collectivités
locales et territoriales apporté au
maintien de ses activités tout à fait
remarquables dans ce secteur-là
qu'en est il de ces risques de voir ces
démissions de moyens précisément au
moment où les agences portent leurs
efforts
et puis je crois que pouvons nous
compter sur votre soutien appuyé mais là
c'est le membre d'un conseil
d'administration de l'agencé du comité
qui parle
6 quelles que soient les majorités en
place je prends quelques précautions
verbal
s'il y avait à nouveau oui je vais loin
dans mes précautions verbal des
mauvaises pensées quand à des
prélèvements sur le budget des agences
par le parlement ou par le gouvernement
tu veux dire s'il y avait des
récidivistes c'est ça monsieur comment
non mais s'il y avait des récidivistes
j'ai pas dis je
monsieur claude berri de basse oui je
voudrais vous remercier pour la clarté
de vos propos et je souhaiterais avoir
un peu plus de précisions sur ce fonds
nous dit vouloir développer une
politique territoriale plus proche je
dirais dedans de nos territoires qu'est
ce que vous entendez par là et quels
seraient les moyens que vous maîtrisez
en oeuvre un merci pour la concision de
la question la parole est à madame
lamure sur qui va suivre
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur vous avez indiqué
que l'inra était le deuxième institut au
monde ce qui est évidemment une source
de fierté et vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos des partenariats mais sont sans
forcément les développer j'aimerais
savoir si vous pratiquez une forme de
partage de connaissance avec d'autres
instituts au monde et où sont plus
particulièrement vos points d'accord
nouveaux points de désaccord dans les
objectifs que je suive ses différents
instituts ok monsieur césar
tu le président vous faites je voudrais
remercier monsieur willy et de sa
présentation aussi qui a été excellente
mais j'ai deux d'autres questions vous
avez dit plusieurs fois si vous me
faites confiance ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui personne ne fait
confiance à a priori mais c'est quoi ce
qui a priori je voulais vous demander
est ce que si vous êtes nommé président
des acteurs général sur qui allez-vous
vous appuyer
vous avez un conseil ministration qui
définissent orientation comment
fonctionnez-vous ce serait intéressant
de pouvoir savoir comment fonctionne
alignera au niveau justement de son
conseil me stration deuxième question
qui rejoint c'est le président allait ce
temps sera ou concernant la recherche et
en particulier ce qui s'est passé à
colmar
roland courteau est parti aussi nous
sommes être tout à fait intéressé pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé à colmar alors
qu'un protocole avait été signé avec
tout le monde et nous avons nous n'avons
pas du tout apprécié le saccage des
plans qui ont été donc mis en place par
l'institut
il n'ira de colmar et nous avons aussi
là je parle au titre de responsable du
rove qui colle tous les problèmes de
court noué qui se pose est aussi de la
flavescence dorée et je voulais savoir
si vous travaillez un partenariat en
particulier avec donc la protection des
végétaux ou du moins ceux qui restent
oui je voulais merci votre présentation
également dans quelques années la terre
donc devra nourrir 9 millions de neuf
milliards d'habitants pardon et pensez
vous que cela est possible sans
actuellement et comment ce défi est il
possible a relevé sans faire appel aux
auprès gm
et deuxième chose les retenues d'eau
c'est autre chose et relis néo l'hiver
afin d'éviter de puiser dans les nappes
phréatiques l'été alors quand on en
parle beaucoup
ça fait des années des années comme le
dit oui mais c'est pas possible
et je crois que pourtant pourtant je ne
vois pas pourquoi ce n'est pas possible
quel est votre point de vue dans ce
demain on continue la selle
monsieur châtillon oui simplement je
vais intervenir mais cette fois avec une
casquette de président d'un pôle de
compétitivité qui s'appelle agrimip
sud-ouest innovation nous ont trahis et
que parler de 20 ans micro ont travaillé
construit ce pôle avec l'inra
aujourd'hui nous avons deux
interlocuteurs inra toulouse inra
bordeaux avec un vice président qui est
suite bordeaux mais qui était
initialement tous comment souci c'est de
savoir si vous entendez continuer cette
collaboration avec les pôles de
compétitivité et tout à l'heure dans
votre dernier roman d'affaires phrase
vous avez parlé de collaboration avec
les deux pays
mais aujourd'hui la france un besoin
évident de regroupement de pme les pays
le plus au genre on déjà leurs services
de recherche et sont sûrement rapport
avec vous dans le domaine et je pense
que les pôles de compétitivité ont un
rôle majeur à jouer pour être une bonne
interface dès l'instant où l'inra est
déjà associé à ces pôles et donc je veux
savoir si vous entendiez continuer cette
politique je peux que te conforter mon
cher collègue châtillon dans ce dans
cette analyse sachant que moi aussi j'ai
un vol de compétitivité du végétal
spécialisé donc ça rejoint tout à fait
et tout le problème en tous les cas du
domaine du végétal c'est un problème de
tpe un tissu extraordinaire docteur en
même temps enfin qu'ils font je dirais
de la recherche et l'innovation sont
sans le savoir comme monsieur jourdain
la parole à monsieur bailly et ensuite à
monsieur mirassou
oui on arrêtera là la salle parce que
merci vous votre exposé en m'excusant
pas des problèmes de transport des
tarifs un petit peu en retard mais
voudrait avoir votre sentiment sur un
sujet qui est assez difficile quand même
je sais bien sûr je connais l'inra pour
y avoir fait deux années de suite les
stages d'immersion que nous propose est
notre président sur les productions
végétales les différents organismes au
tour d'ici de sa capitale et puis à
texte pour tout ce qui est production
animale est également le réchauffement
avec tous les essais que vous faites là
bas donc c'est vrai que j'apprécie votre
travail comme je vois aussi le travail
que vous faites l inra de pollini plus
particulièrement en termes laitiers je
travaille actuellement travail
difficiles avec madame nicoud qui est
ici parce qu'on a la commission
prospective nous a chargé à 3 sur
l'avenir des campagnes à damir des
campagnes à l'horizon 2030 2040
donc on a déjà fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de fin d'audition y compris
part de vos collaborateurs aux fins des
gens d'hydra langue très dit très
diversifié mais pour savoir l'avenir des
campagnes elles dépensent aussi qu'elle
ma tête la compétitivité d'un de ce qui
est quand même important dans nos
campagnes l'agriculture et vous l'avez
évoqué mais mené bien petit peu
rapidement est ce que notre agriculture
et comment travaillez vous pour que cet
agriculteur en 2030 2040 soit toujours
bien présentes sur le territoire mais
pour qu'elle soit présente
on sait que nos voisins allemands nous
ont pris pas mal de parts de marché bien
toutes ces dernières années on sent
aussi que tous caire le sud le sud
d'amérique cécité hidhab a aussi son
prendre un de prendre aussi beaucoup de
parts de marché alors je crois quand
même qu'il faut pas oublier du tout que
on veut que notre agriculture est
compétitive tout en ayant bien sûr la
qualité alors vu quand même qu'on compte
beaucoup sur l'inra est une référence je
crois que que ce soit pour les chambres
d'agriculture dans lesquelles j'ai été
président pendant un certain nombre
d'années
quelle est votre vision sur les deux ou
trois décennies qui viennent pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que notre
agriculture soit bien présentes sur le
territoire et dans quels domaines pensez
qu'on a le plus d'atouts
si les paroles de monsieur mirassou moi
je vais émettre propos plus généraliste
qui va s'appuyer sur la reconnaissance
de l'inra par rapport à sa qualité
non seulement une recherche mais
également d' expertise et que je dis ça
je me demande et je vous demande sans
rentrer dans une valorisation excessive
quel est le rôle que pourrait jouer
l'inra pour faire en sorte que l'opinion
publique de manière lapidaire j'ai le
formuler y voit plus clair que j'ai ici
je pense notamment aux débats qui
commencent à être initiées sur les ogm
il faut bien se mettre à la place de
ceux qui ne sont pas complètement
initiés et qui ont la perception qu'on
me dit tout le contraire de tout je
pense comme un des nôtres il faudra se
donner les moyens là comme ailleurs là
puisque ailleurs de sortir par rapport à
ces gens là d'une forme d'obscurantisme
et trouver le juste milieu entre le
scientisme et l'obscurantisme et voilà
que ma parole éminemment philosophique
et je crois que vous avez un rôle très
important à jouer dans ce registre là
j'ai déjà entendu cette phrase célèbre
ta bouche trop chers grecs
oui tout à fait la parole aux deux
derniers intervenants parce que sinon on
va pas s'en sortir et pour un vote qui
devrait intervenir vers 20 h 20
votre réponse bien entendu monsieur
burqa monsieur l'abbé monsieur bourque
un accord rapidement on est tous
d'accord moi je vais vous remercier pour
votre propos liminaire de belles
qualités et qui commet pour pose
beaucoup de questions mais simplement je
reposerai simplement une très
généraliste aussi pensez vous que
l'agriculture française et européenne
peut devenir une agriculture moderne qui
préserve mieux son environnement mais
qui en même temps peut se passer des ogm
on nous présente la question des objets
m com
nu comme une décision inéluctable et
est-ce qu'on peut développer une
agriculture moderne de qualité sans les
ogm
j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis parce
que vous avez abordé un peu le sujet si
la parole à monsieur l'abbé oui j'étais
retenu l'excusé montargis la fin du scud
merci m'excuser quand même j'ai entendu
la fin de votre provost qui maquille mme
hakima bien intéresser
j'aurai une question par rapport à
l'agrochimie et là les autorisations de
mise sur le marché d'un certain nombre
de molécules
on se rencontre je suis la mission
d'information pesticides avec intérêt
donc un certain nombre de mise sur le
marché sont remises en question et
d'ailleurs elles le sont dans les fêtes
quelques années après assez souvent
il semblerait qu'il y ait un défaut de
contre expertise et d'une contre
expertise qui soit indépendante et si
possible public alors est-ce que vous à
la tête de l'inra vous pourriez avec les
moyens qui vont avec
être à même d'assurer 7,7 cette contre
expertise neutre indépendante est tenu
par le secret parce qu'on nous met
toujours en avant maintenant les secrets
de fabrication ne peut pas donner tous
les tous les éléments non mais je pense
qu'il ya besoin d'un organisme public où
se nouent parapublic qui pourrait être
celui là je voudrais savoir quel est
votre point de vue s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur vouliez vous avez la parole
vous avez vu cette salve de questions
donc il ya en tous les cas un thème qui
revient relativement souvent dans
l'ensemble que ce soit chez madame nico
chez martial bourquin sur la nourriture
nourrir la planète etc
et accessoirement évidemment on retombe
sur eux
l'intérêt des pgm bon je vous laisse
maître de la réponse parce que vu le
nombre de questions bon courage
mais écoutez merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vais tâcher effectivement de te répondre
de manière groupée à quelques unes des
questions que vous m'avez posé en tout
cas si je n'arrivais pas à le faire dans
le temps qui est un parti j'ai bien noté
que vous en avez posé un grand nombre
c'est témoigne de votre intérêt je pense
que mes collègues et moi les avons noté
donc si jamais je n'y répondrai pas je
m'attacherai à le faire dans les
semaines qui suivent la première
question qu'une des premières questions
que j'ai posées concernent la
communication de nos travaux alors ce
n'est pas je reviendrai après la
question des organismes et des pgm sur
cette question de la communication de
travaux nous avons conscience du fait
effectivement que les citoyens sont en
attente alors pas que les citoyens et
les citoyens les entreprises les
filières et donc on est dans un
processus de refonte de notre site
internet avec l'idée d'avoir un site qui
nous permettent d'assurer transparence
et pédagogie et d'avoir une entrée qui
soit plus par très grandes thématiques
et donc je pense que sur un site de ce
type là vous trouverez effectivement des
réponses à la scène questions que vous
n'avez pas posé comme l'adaptation au
changement climatique ou des questions
du type de celle que vous avez posé sûr
que fait de boudu sur tel domaine sur
les abeilles que faites-vous sur les
soldes vont souvent la question des sols
que faites-vous sur l'eau donc ça c'est
une réponse un peu technique mais je
crois que c'est effectivement important
pour l'institut comme l'inra que d'avoir
cette capacité à dire ce qu'il fait est
à dire aussi ce qu'il a trouvé et ce
qu'il sait les deux choses sont un petit
peu différente sur quoi travaille on
nous sur quelques elle recherche manono
et quels résultats vont nous obtenu il
ya bien deux temps un peu différent là
dans notre action et je crois qu'il est
nécessaire que nous rendions mieux
visible notre action en la matière sur
la question des plantes génétiquement
modifiées maintenant parce que c'est
effectivement une question importante et
qui nous est régulièrement posée
alors tout d'abord un premier
commentaire sur ce qui s'est passé à
colmar à colmar nous avons effectivement
pris toute une série de dispositions
pour consulter très tôt très en amont
l'ensemble des parties prenantes nous
n'avons pas souhaité que ces parties
prenantes décide de ce que nous ferions
mais nous avons entendu leur message et
nous avons adopté adapté des protocoles
les façons de travailler aux suggestions
qui avait pu être faite ici ou là et
nous l'avons fait en responsabilité en
transparence tellement transparent ce
qu'on peut on avait désigné de façon
très claire les 35 mètres carrés qui ont
été arrachés puisque c'était
parfaitement que du donc tous tout ça a
été construit de manière très très
ouverte et très transparent et pour être
sincère
nous sommes choqués nous avons été
choqués et nous restons choqué de cette
de cet arrachage et donc le ce titre là
nous avons le nous l'avons exprimée par
les professionnels en portant plate
donc ça c'était peut-être sur le cas
particulier de colmar de façon plus
générale l'institut après avoir
sollicité son comité d'éthique au début
des années 2000 son conseil scientifique
en 2005 a aussi sollicité son conseil
d'administration sur ce sujet et il est
rare que le conseil d'administration de
l'institut prennent les délibérations de
nature particulière sur un sujet de
politique spécifiques et on qu'en 2007
il ya eu une décision du conseil
d'administration qui a arrêté la
politique de l'institut en la matière et
c'est que l'essai de politique et se
résume en fait sûrs en quatre en quatre
mots essentiels
l'idée que nous devons être compétent il
n'est pas possible qu'un organisme comme
l'inra ne soit pas compétent sur ce
sujet là parce que que l'épée gm soit ou
non cultivées en france un moment ou un
autre nous seront interrogés donc il
faut que nous soyons compétents il faut
que quand nous faisons des recherches
dans ce domaine nous soyons pertinents
il est clair que ce n'est pas un
organisme comme in rats de refaire ou
d'imaginer des plantes génétiquement
modifiées du type de celle que
l'industrie et est actuellement capable
de faire mais il ya différentes types tu
plantes génétiquement modifiées vous
avez les plantes actuellement tolérantes
aux herbicides et nous nous voyons en
amérique du nord qu'elle touche un
certain nombre de limites
après quelques avantages positifs on
voit aujourd'hui qu'il y à des espèces
de mauvaises herbes qui devient
résistantes et on voit bien qu'ils aient
des difficultés que vous avez un
deuxième type d'ogive vous avez des ogm
qui sont résistants des pgm qui sont
résistantes à des bureaux des soeurs
hélas le bilan et pop pas forcément
aussi négatif qu'il est et on a même eu
récemment un article qui a été réalisée
par un chercheur de l'inra qui a fait
une analyse de développement du coton
ogm en chine et qui montre que à
certains égards ça peut être dans
certaines circonstances favorables y
compris pour certains éléments de
biodiversité parce que ça évite de
mettre des pesticides en masse et puis
vous avez d'autres types de gm qui
peuvent arriver dans le futur qui
peuvent être par exemple des ogm qui
serait plus proche d'un bien public
imaginons qu'il y ait un moment ou un
autre des pistes sérieuses il y en
existe vous avez peut-être plus que les
noces homologues britanniques viennent
de publier une annonce d'un projet qui
consiste à travailler sur la fixation
bactérienne de la zot pour les céréales
bons voeux des sujets de ce genre là
peuvent être intéressantes pour réduire
l' usage de les âges d'intrants lusage
de fertilisants donc il nous faut si
nous choisissons de travailler sur ces
sujets là être pertinents ensuite il
nous faut être parcimonieux parce
qu'effectivement nous savons que la
société ne souhaite pas en l'état
travailler sur ces sujets et il nous
faut être clair et transparent c'est à
dire faire dire ce que nous faisons et
puis en rendre compte ensuite
j'ajouterai juste cette description
rapide sur les travaux que nous enfin
sur la position de l'institut sur les
organismes génétiquement modifiés parce
qu'actuellement nous n'avons l'essai de
colmar a été arraché et donc
les des recherches qui seraient tournés
vers l'utilisation de pgm il n'y en a
pas mais si je rajouterais peut-être un
point c'est que en même temps nous
souhaitons pouvoir aborder des approches
alternatives et il existe des voies
conventionnel qui permettent de traiter
sur un certain nombre de traits sur
chalon de sujets qui permettent
d'améliorer ou d'accélérer le progrès
génétique
vous savez peut-être que des
technologies qu'on qualifie de sélection
génomique de sélection assistée par
marqueurs permettent d'accélérer très
très sensible devant les procédés
visuels d'amélioration des plantes et
par exemple sur le blé mais nous faisons
aussi sur les bovins parce qu'il est
important travail à la fois sur l'animal
et sur le végétal il y effectivement des
processus de ce type là où des
recherches de ce type là qui sont
conduites et qui permettent d'accélérer
sensiblement le progrès génétique qui
soient animales ou végétales par des
voies que qui veut qu'on pourra
qualifier de classique
voilà donc un peu rapidement ce que je
peux dire peut-être sur cette question
des plantes génétiquement modifiées en
complément deux ou en réponse aux
questions que vous avez évoqué sur la
question que qu'elle était posée par le
sénateur hérisson sur à la fois la
protection des milieux aquatiques
puisque nous faisons plus précisément à
thonon les bains alors l'inra n'est pas
le seul à intervenir sur cette question
des milieux aquatiques mais nous avons
effectivement un certain nombre d'unités
de recherche à thonon sur les sur les
sur les grands lacs en l'occurrence
alpin nous avons des outils de recherche
sur les petit fleuve côtier
à rennes nous avons des unités de
recherche à saint pée sur nivelle en
pays basque et qui travaillent sur
différents types d'écosystèmes aquatique
effectivement nous sommes intéressés non
seulement à certains égards à des
questions de nature piscicole ou de
l'aquaculture mais nous sommes aussi
intéressés à la qualité des milieux la
qualité des milieux aquatiques donc nous
avons des recherches dans ce domaine là
et nous avons bien l'intention de
continuer à les mener quand la mesure
des moyens dont nous disposons vont bien
évidemment
et s'agissant thonon les bains c'est
effectivement un site dans lequel il ya
eu un certain nombre de départs mais
dans lequel nous avons aussi procédé à
un certain nombre de recrutements et
dans lequel nous pensons qu'il est
important d'équilibrer les compétences
que nous avons sur le fonctionnement
biogéochimiques du lac et les
compétences que nous avons par exemple
sur les poissons les populations de
poissons qui sont présents dans ce lac
donc oui clairement thonon les bains ou
plus je suis l'ancien chef du
département écologie des forêts prairies
et milieux aquatiques et j'ai donc j'ai
eu l'occasion de lire plusieurs fois à
thonon les bains et donc j'incite tous
ceux d'entre vous qui souhaiteraient
savoir ce que nous faisons dans ces
domaines a visité cette station parce
que c'est plutôt une belle station on a
failli avoir un très beau succès à vous
annoncer on l'a pas vu mais on a une
jeune chercheur de thonon qui a été
short listés pour être dans les
candidates lauréate a annoncé le conseil
européen de la recherche
donc elle est allée jusqu'aux phase
finale de sélection une autre candidate
a été sélectionné pour l'inra dans un
autre site mais enfin donc ça veut dire
qu'on est bien en plus des gens de
qualité dans cet endroit sur la question
de la politique territoriale que vous
m'avez posé aussi le sénateur berry des
mois l'idée que nous avons et ça n'est
pas nouveau à l'inra c'est que comme
nous sommes profondément ancré dans les
territoires nous avons 18 centres mais
nous avons 100 sites physiques ce qui
est quand même important
il est effectivement important pour nous
de travailler avec l'ensemble des
partenaires alors non seulement avec les
partenaires
socioprofessionnelles et j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure à propos des pôles de
compétitivité et titi vitae mais aussi
de travailler avec eux les partenaires
académiques
alors nous avions dans les années 2000
milieu des années 2000 quatre feuilles
des schémas de centre qui permettait de
fixer une sorte de politique du site
nous venons de refaire cet exercice là
il y à quelques quelques mois et nous
comptons nous appuyer sur ces schémas de
centre pour finalement élaboré avec nos
partenaires académiques les universités
les écoles d'ingénieurs les autres
organismes de recherche les instituts
techniques qui peuvent être présents des
politiques de site et ce qui est
important pour nous et ce que j'ai voulu
exprimer tout à l'heure en matière de
politique de site c'est que nous sommes
essentiellement attaché est intéressé à
ce que à mettre en place des espaces de
projets qu'ils soient collaboratif et
qui soient respectueux de nos missions
celle des universités celle des écoles
celle des autres organismes de recherche
qui sont présents et puis b celle de
l'institut qui est un institut national
donc nous souhaitons avoir des
politiques de site qui effectivement
soient conformes à nos orientations
nationales et c'est à ce titre là que
nous avons élaboré des schémas de
centres et nous considérons que ces
politiques de site académique ouverte
aussi aux partenaires sociaux
professionnels qu'elles doivent dépasser
la simple liste des unités mixtes de
recherche que nous avons avec tel ou tel
organisme
elles doivent être plus englobante est
porté sur l'ensemble des thématiques que
nous avons dans l'un ou l'autre des 18
centres de l'institut
bon je sais pas si ça répond à la
question mais c'est bien cette idée là
que nous souhaitons porter à travers ces
politiques du site sur la question du
des pôles de compétitivité
il doit y avoir une quinzaine j'en ai
pas la liste exacte de pôles de
compétitivité qui sont compétents en
france dans le domaine de l'agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire ou de la forêt nous
sommes effectivement attache pas attaché
à travailler vécu je serais pas capable
en l'état de vous dire le nombre de
projets que nous avons plus labellisés
au travers de ses pôles de compétitivité
mais il y en a eu un nombre tout à fait
significatif
s'agissant plus particulièrement du pôle
que vous présidez qui a été labellisé un
peu plus tard que d'autres c'est quand
même un de ceux pour lequel nous avons
le plus de projets qui ont été
labellisés donc ça veut dire que c'est
un pôle qui effectivement est actif et
s'est élargi
à la région aquitaine nous considérons
effectivement qu'il a un grand ensemble
qui qui fait sens et pour donner un
exemple du un peu concret de la
politique que nous avons suivis et que
je souhaite que nous suivions dans les
prochaines années quand nous avons créé
le groupement d'intérêt scientifique
biotechnologies vertes que j'évoquais au
début de mon propos est un groupement
d'intérêt scientifique qui vise à
développer l'ensemble des technologies
dont nous pouvons avoir besoin pour pour
faire évoluer l'agriculture dans la
partie végétale donc dans ce groupement
d'intérêt scientifique vous y trouvez
tous les organismes publics de recherche
qui sont concernés par ce sujet vous y
trouvez par ailleurs des instituts
techniques
arvalis cetiom vous y trouvez des
entreprises des entreprises semencières
et nous sommes attachés à ce qu'il est
non seulement les plus grandes d'entre
elles mais aussi des plus petites comme
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
monsieur le président elia 3 pôles de
compétitivité il y à céréales vallée il
ya les mimines ovation et il y a le pôle
de compétitivité du végétal spécialisé à
angers et nous avons trouvé qu'il était
particulièrement intéressant d'articuler
ces deux dimensions à nouveau une
dimension nationale parce que c'est
notre mandat est une dimension qui est
plus territoriale qui est plus ceux liés
à l'animation locale mais parfois de
portée nationale ou internationale qui
est porté par ses pôles de compétitivité
donc nous avons bien l'intention de
continuer à travailler dans cette voie
sur la manière dont nous travaillerons
si vous si vous me faites confiance
parce qu'effectivement je suis ici
aujourd'hui j'ai j'attendrai votre vote
avec ou moins attention jusqu'à la
semaine prochaine
si vous me faites confiance bon l'inra
une gouvernance interne qui est
collégiale et je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure de façon rapide moi j'y suis
attaché donc qu'il y ait un collège de
direction qui est actuellement formé de
deux directeur général délégué michel
est dit et moi même et donc je pense que
la présence de michel et dit à mes côtés
et aujourd'hui et sans doute un signe de
notre intérêt à continuer à travailler
de façon collective
il ya des directeurs scientifiques et
j'échoue voilà on peut le voir de
différentes
c'est du travail des équipes donc il ya
des directeurs scientifiques qui font
partie de ce collège de direction il ya
le directeur de celui qui est délégué l
expertise à la prospective aux études
donc nous sommes attachés à cette forme
collective de gouvernance il ya par
ailleurs effectivement un conseil
d'administration qui est l'organe qui
décide qui est de l'organe décisionnaire
de l'institut est ce ce conseil bien
évidemment moi si je suis nommé des
premières tâches indépendamment de la
première réunion du conseil migration ce
sera donc de rencontrer les
administrateurs pour savoir
effectivement qu'elles sont
éventuellement les indications qu'il
souhaiterait que nous suivions au delà
des administrateurs qui sont les
tutelles que qui sont par ailleurs
présente sur ce que nous faisons en
matière de viticulture au sens large
alors c'est vrai qu'on travaille sur le
cours d'eau et pas simplement au travers
les travaux prennent manioc à colmar
mais sur l'ensemble du spectre on
travaille sur la flemme les errances
flavescence dorée nous avons beaucoup
d'interactions actuellement sur les
questions relatives au mildiou et
l'oïdium et la création de variétés qui
ne sont pas payés mais qui sont obtenues
par des voies classiques de variétés qui
sont résistantes au milieu et l'oïdium
et nous espérons bien d'ici deux trois
ans être capable de le diffuser des
variétés avec des résistances
polygénique obtenu par des voies
conventionnelle et qui permettront de
réduire sensiblement les usages des
fongicides qui sont quand même en
matière de déficit culture
un des points un des points qui est
critique sur la question de comment
nourrir 9 milliards d'habitants et un
peu généralement avant de se reposer la
question des plantes génétiquement
modifiées
je comprends qu'elle vous intéresse
d'abord c'est un véritable défi c'est à
dire que nous avons su passer dans les
50 dernières années de 2 3 milliards
d'habitants 3 milliards et demi à 7
milliard nous avons sur même temps
augmenter la production
nous avons conduit dans les années
passées et nous poursuivons cet exercice
une prospective qui s'appelle agrimonde
que nous avons conduite avec le cirad
cette prospective sous différents
scénarios indique qu'on vous doit
pouvoir arriver à nourrir 50 9 milliards
d'habitants en 2050 et non pas 50
milliards 2009 donc bien d'habitants en
2050 on devrait pouvoir le faire à
plusieurs conditions
la première c'est de limiter les pertes
et les gaspillages qui sont quand même
un des sujets importants
la deuxième ce sera nécessairement de
regarder nos régimes alimentaires si
nous décidons tous de manger de façon
très caloriques
nous aurons certainement quelques
difficultés et nous aurons à augmenter
encore sensiblement plus les rendements
et les surfaces troisièmement nous
serons obligés d'augmenter les
rendements
il n'y a pas de venir a pas
d'échappatoire à ça et c'est un
forestier qui vous le dit quelqu'un qui
est attachée à la biodiversité
si nous n'augmentons pas les rendements
la variable d'ajustement ce seront les
écosystèmes naturels
or je ne crois pas que ce soit ce que
souhaitent nos concitoyens donc
nécessairement il y aura besoin
d'augmenter les rendements d'une manière
ou d'une autre et puis quatrièmement
toutes les régions ne sont
malheureusement pas lotis de la même
manière face à ces questions de sécurité
alimentaire et du raz forcément des
échanges et du commerce entre des
régions qui sont plus productrices et
des régions qui quelle sombre donc à ce
prix là je pense qu'effectivement nous
nous voyons que nous avons des capacités
qui doivent permettre de nourrir 9
milliards d'habitants
mais nous ne jouerons pas sur un seul
levier nous serons obligés de jouer sur
l'ensemble de cette et leviers que je
viens d'évoquer
et à ce titre là et je reviens sur le
propos que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
même si actuellement nous n'avons pas à
l'inra de travaux qui soit pour la
création de plantes génétiquement
modifiées nous utilisons la transgénèse
dans nos recherches mais nous n'avons
pas effectivement de projet particulier
dédié à la création de pornic je pense
qu'il faut rester prudent et que nul
n'est en situation d'une certaine
manière d'injurier l'avenir je nous
sommes attentifs au projet qui peuvent
être menées dans d'autres régions du
monde nous sommes attentifs à ce que
font les chinois nous sommes attentifs
au projet que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui a été conduits par des britanniques
et qui vise à transférer la capacité de
symbiose bactérienne et de fixation de
l'azoté sur les céréales
ça peut être un facteur d'amélioration
des rendements il faut regarder ce genre
de projet là avec attention sur
la question si vous en avez posé
beaucoup donc je ne suis pas tout à fait
sûrs d'arriver à répondre à tout sur sur
la question de l' expertise sur lui sur
les molécules mises en marché je crois
qu'il faut que chacun reste un peu dans
son rôle nous avait en outre que nous
avons eu des résultats récemment sur les
sur les abeilles qui ont permis de
mettre en évidence qu'il pouvait y avoir
un risque particulier le résultat obtenu
c'est un résultat de recherche
il est important qu'un organisme comme
l'inra s'occupe de recherche il ya par
ailleurs déjà des agences qui sont en
charge de l' expertise et son nationale
elles sont européennes et c'est à ces
agences de conduire les expertises et de
la conduire de manière indépendante
nous fournissons nous mêmes un vivier
important d'experts à ses agences et
donc il me paraît naturel que nous
fournissions cette expertise mais mes 7
mai les experts de l'inra qui
interviennent à ce titre là ils
interviennent à titre privé et nous
avons été amenés dans les années passées
et je pense que c'est un point important
havre a élaboré une charte de
l'expertisé qu'ils puissent régler à la
fois ce que nous faisons quand nous
réalisons d expertise scientifique
collective sur des questions qui peuvent
nous est posée par nos tutelles pour
l'émissaire qui pourrait nous être
posées par la représentation nationale
donc quand nous faisons d expertise
scientifique collective nous avons une
certaine déontologie certaines méthodes
nous appuyons sur des résultats de
recherche
et puis nous avons aussi une charte de
l'expertisé qui permet de régler
l'implication de nos chercheurs
individuellement dans des expertises qui
sont réalisées par les agences dont
c'est le métier que de faire ces
expertises d'accréditation
d'homologation des produits
phytosanitaires ou des produits
antibiotiques ou d'autres produits
chimiques et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement que nous sachions
équilibrée note opposition être
différents et complémentaires les uns
des autres sur la question vous est
posée sur l'avenir des campagnes je
terminerai peut-être là-dessus monsieur
le président si vous en êtes d'accord
d'une part nous avons conduit à quelques
années une prospective sur les nouvelles
ruralités qui était une prospective
effectivement sur sur les campagnes sur
et compris sur la relation campagne vile
clairement pour qu'il y avait je
souscris à ce que vous avez est ce que
vous avez dit si nous souhaitons avoir
une agriculture en france il faudra
qu'elle soit compétitive
la question de cette compétitivité quand
on le regarde on voit qu'il ya en gros
deux grands types de questions qui se
posent il ya des questions qui sont
liées
donc on évoque assez régulièrement au
coût de la main d'oeuvre à des
distorsions de concurrence entre pays en
europe ces points là ne peuvent pas être
ignorées mais il ya aussi des questions
qui sont relatives à l'organisation des
filières en france et que cette
organisation ce soit sur l'amont la
structuration de la production où que ce
soit sur la balle il apparaît assez
clairement que l'on discute avec nos
collègues économiste à l'inra ou à
l'extérieur qu'il y a des marges de
progrès à 6 sensible en matière de
structuration des filières que ce soit
des filières animales des filières du
lait ou et des filières végétales qui a
des marges de progrès qui sont
importants et il est clair que
l'excédent commercial que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure rapidement est un
excédent commercial qui est fragile
parce qu'il est fondée essentiellement
sur deux segments particuliers les
produits terroir d'un côté dont
notamment les produits de la viticulture
et d'autre part des produits de base
comme comme les céréales que nous
exportons et est donc effectivement
cette question de la compétitivité est
une question qui est importante que nous
travaillons avec nos collègues
économistes en apportant nos éclairages
ce n'est pas nous qui règle les
questions de compétitivité ce que nous
pouvons faire c'est apporter un
éclairage de nos économistes ce que nous
pouvons faire aussi ce que nous faisons
par exemple puisque tel laboratoire
d'excellence dans grant west n'a pas été
sélectionné alors que nous l'aurions
souhaité à nous déposons un projet
structurant sur les pôles de
compétitivité sur la filière laitière
avec nos collègues de rennes parce que
nous considérons sur cette filiale a
représentent savent voilà donc les
suites de sa fille on essaye de rebondir
en essayant de déposer un projet
structurant sur la compétitivité de la
filière laitière prises depuis l'amont
agricole jusqu'à laval
à laval de la transformation voilà
monsieur le président et messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs des
réponses dont j'ai conscience qu'elles
ne sont pas forcément complète à toutes
les questions que vous m'avez posé mais
je m'attacherai avec mes trois collègues
ici présents à éventuellement répondra
ultérieurement à celle qui resterait
monsieur oui je pense qu'il y aura
l'occasion de se rencontrer et ne serait
ce qu'avec le groupe d'étude sur
l'agriculture et pour approfondir un
certain nombre de sujets qu on n'a pas
eu le temps de creuser la question alors
juste une petite précision vient de vaud
distribuer des bulletins
vous répondez par oui ou par non à la
question posée n'est ce pas non mais je
fais pas allusion au référendum
là il s'agit bien est-ce que de deux
commandes accepté la candidature de
monsieur ollier à la direction enfin la
présidence en fait je confonds toujours
un peu dans vos centres d'ailleurs entre
un directeur président du centre enfin
chacun son jargon à la présidence de
l'inra c'est oui ou c'est non
d'accord j'ai bien clair et c'est pas
c'est pas en mettant le nom la question
c'est acceptez-vous la candidature alors
maintenant vous avez le droit de si
j'ose dire
alors madame la sénatrice chez le camp
profiterait donc prendre pour répondre à
votre question nous avons effectivement
si la question posée l'été celle des
partenariats avec d autres
établissements étrangers
alors nous avons un tissu de partenariat
ah si important en europe évidemment au
titre de tout ce qui est le programme
cadre avec l'université de wageningen
vont avec nos homologues britanniques
homologue allemand ou espagnol
nous avons aussi des collaborations plus
largement dans le reste du monde et nous
considérons que les grands programmes
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure ses
programmes sur l'adaptation au
changement climatique ses programmes sur
la gestion intégrée de la santé des
plantes ou de la santé animale ses
programmes sur la métagénomique du tube
digestif la métagénomique des sols ces
programmes là sont le support de nos
collaborations avec ces organismes
alors quel est notre posture on essaye
de travailler des organismes publics qui
sont homologue à l'inra et donc on
s'attache à pouvoir échanger des
informations de nature scientifique
on a par exemple régulièrement des
collaborations et des liens avec notre
homologue américain qui l agricultural
research service avec avic fou d
agriculture canada est avec nous nos
collègues britanniques on les a
rencontrés à toulouse il ya peu de temps
une fois par an on a l'occasion de
rencontrer l'ensemble de ses partenaires
on a des échanges de chercheurs ont co
publie 46% des publications l'inra 46%
des bulles est question d'une race sont
avec des collègues étrangers et 27% sont
avec des collègues européens donc ça
veut dire que entre l'europe et le grand
international que ce soit l'australie
les etats-unis le brésil l'argentine il
ya effectivement il ya effectivement
sortes de choses qui se passent moi je
sais pas si ça répond à votre question
mais faire en complément j'aurais
souhaité savoir si
tu dans le mondial partagez pas du tout
les objectifs de certains je dirais que
sur les grands objectifs que j'ai
évoquées dans ma vision de la recherche
agronomique nous nous y retrouvons
globalement il y à quelques îles
quelques différences sur deux points
l'inra est sans doute un des organismes
si ce n'est l'organisme qui est le plus
écrit libre et sur les trois piliers du
tripode que j'évoquais tout à l'heure à
la culture alimentation environnement
certains sont plus agricole que nous ne
le sommes et donc nous essayons
effectivement de bien faire valoir ses
trois dimensions la et leurs
interactions
après il ya aussi des différences entre
ceux qui sont plus appliquées et ce qui
serait plus académique les universités
par essence auront tendance à être plus
académique
certains instituts qui sont nos
homologues pensons par exemple aux
brésiliens seront un peu plus appliqués
que nous le sommes seront aussi parfois
peut être plus directement couplé à
l'industrie et dans des situations qui
nous amène à être prudents dans les
collaborations que nous pouvons avoir
avec eux et donc nous nous attacherons
avec ses différents instituts à repérer
ceux qui ont en gros les mêmes valeurs
pour travailler avec lui sur des
segments d'activités qui sont des
segments d'activité qui correspondent à
des biens publics qui sont effectivement
des biens publics partageable à
l'échelle de la planète
quand on va arriver sur des questions
qui peuvent être plus directement
intéressante pour la compétitivité des
uns et des autres effectivement nous
aurons les uns et des autres d'aider
sorte de devoir de réserve ou un devoir
de de préférence dans de collaboration
oui ne pas se faire il n'y aura pas
beaucoup c'est le bras armé alors cette
question des protéines et l'effectif
important
nous nous sommes à la fois comment dire
on peut dire qu'on en fait je partage le
constat que vous avez fait le constat
est ennuyeux c'est au moins deux angles
c'est que d'une part c'est cette
importation et d'autre part y'a
l'agronomie
finalement je vous ai peut parler
d'agronomie mais une partie de l'intérêt
des espèces qui génère des protéines
sont qu'elles sont fixatrices d'azoté
qu'elle joue un rôle positif dans les
assolements alors donc nous considérons
effectivement qu'il est important de
mener des recherches importantes sur les
légumineuses pour faire pour faire pour
faire court et et nous sommes quand vous
comparez si vous vous posiez la question
madame la sénatrice lamure sur des
choses qui marquent notre différence par
rapport aux deux organismes
même si l'économie agricole française
utilise finalement peu les protéagineux
même si le poids a sensiblement reculé
mais pas pour des questions de recherche
un principalement pour des questions de
nature économique même si donc ces
choses existent
nous avons maintenu une recherche sur le
poids qui est sensiblement supérieur y
compris dans le domaine de la génétique
celle que nous trouverions chez
pratiquement n'importe lequel de nos
homologues européens ou étrangers donc
nous l'avons fait dans un contexte qui
était défavorable nous faisons à dijon
nous avons un projet investissements
d'avenir qui a été retenu sur ce sujet
qui s'appelle pme qui associe l'ensemble
des partenaires industriels comme les
socioprofessionnels potentiellement
concernés donc nous considérons
effectivement qu'il est important
d'autres continuent à faire des
recherches sur ce sujet mais à nouveau
nous faisons les recherches
nous ne sommes pas responsables un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont par
ailleurs déterminante pour la décision
des agriculteurs de cultiver ou non
des légumineuses et ensuite de produire
des protéines merci monsieur oublié je
pense que tout le monde n'a pu voter
merci en tous les cas l'ensemble de
votre présentation je suis persuadé que
cela même suscité d'autres questions qui
sera en aura une occasion de se revoir